what kind of stuff do you stream so
advice you talk about yeah like either I
talk to chat or I travel around
basically like crew to have a
conversations where we like
um go to countries I've been to like
Italy I was gonna live like one and a
half months just like traveling around
alone going to cities like having like
my camera with me and like streaming for
hours where's the where's the coolest
place you've been to ever it's probably
New Zealand New Zealand I think so yeah
after it's probably going to be Italy I
think because they're like history and
yeah also both history because New
Zealand is also beautiful it does both
natural beauty and historical Beauty
yeah for sure I think I just really like
the like the Polynesian sort of culture
I think is very interesting like the
ocean people and it's just really
beautiful people are very relaxed chill
they're very far away which is
interesting as well because whenever
they talk about politics or they talk
about
um just like the world it feels really
far away
so where's home for you is Austin home
did you home for me a human being is
home yeah we travel we've lived in a lot
of different places and traveled around
yeah so that's what you think of home is
like I think so yeah I mean if they're
gonna be a place it's probably gonna be
like my childhood places probably yeah
like my old country house or something
like that we don't have it anymore but
like that's that's like home for me I
guess